well here we are your name's thing
called you are on the cast it's
happening I can't stop the train it's
already left the station it has no good
not just yet what are you most nervous
about when it comes to competing or
dancing the fact that everyone's
watching me reintroduce my body to dance
and I'm not as young as I look you guys
know thank you find out shocking
you got a cave you can take any
inspiration from your character Meredith
from over in the office you know I
really think of my journey in this
business and in my life I've always been
a late bloomer so you know I'm 55 and
I'm I can't believe I've decided that
it's okay for free dance but you know
but a lot of people take themselves out
of the race so I'm just here to say like
I'm the poster child for hang in there
and maybe you still can do it and we'll
find out together America your partner
has not been announced just yet no I've
been very nice to the dancers because I
don't know who I'm dancing you seriously
don't know seriously do not I do not
where do you find out Monday yeah and
then you'll jump into rehearsals yes you
have your eye on a throw in particular I
love them all and I thought if I say who
I want I don't want to be publicly
humiliated more than
[Laughter]
no matter what happens it's gonna be
that's gonna be fast but we look forward
to seeing your skills on the dance let's
see if they translate to the ballroom
floor and yes but you know I mean if
nothing else we'll have a we'll have a
drink and laugh over this lol thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]